and ladies and gentlemen I try to bring
you the best
I try to bring you the best
amen Dr Joel Wall's work has resulted in
the publication of more than 70 peer
review and and and uh ref referred
Journal articles in the fields of
nutrition and pharmaceutical research he
promotes worldwide health Beauty and
Youthful energy and for more than 40
years it has been Dr Wall's mission to
bring bring accurate and timely health
information to the world ladies and
gentlemen I want you to stand to your
feet and welcome our speaker for the
next couple of nights as he takes us on
a journey to achieving the health that
we want please welcome Dr Joel wallik as
he comes at this time oh thank you
Pastor dollar and Pastor Taffy and his
whole crew they've been so wonderful now
the next thing we want to talk about is
dementias how many of you ever heard of
Alzheimer's disease raise your hand okay
good now Alzheimer's disease is a
physician caused disease it's not
genetic Alzheimer disease is a physician
caused disease it is not
genetic now you're not the mom of a
doctor are
you okay now listen my wife is a surgeon
I love doctors I love doctors and they
do have their place but in this case
doctors have caused this disease 40
years ago Alzheimer's disease didn't
exist even by another
name alimer disease did not exist 40
years ago even by another name today
it's the number four killer of adults
over the age of 65 so just a short
period of time has become a huge huge
problem for industrialized countries 85%
of all Alzheimer disease is diagnosed in
the world I'm going to repeat that 85%
of all Alzheimer disease diagnosed in
the world is diagnosed in
America it's an American disease created
by American doctors
because 75% of your brain weight is a
fatty insulation material called myin
how many of you heard of myin okay good
it myin makes up 75% of your brain
weight it's the white matter of the
brain the gray matter the the thinking
cells and the memory cells sitting on
top of the white matter which is this
white fatty insulation material makes up
75% of your brain weight and when the
myin goes away you get Alzheimer disease
because the naked nerve fibers all Shard
out and they look for nerve Tangles with
CAT scans and that's how they diagnose
Alzheimer dis
disease well Alzheimer disease is caused
by this milin going away milin makes up
75% of your brain weight milin is 100%
cholesterol so if you're on a
cholesterol restricted diet you're
taking cholesterol oring drugs guess
what you're going to
get Alzheimer
disease so you have to dump the
cholesterol oring drugs you have to
start eating 10 eggs a
day no fried foods no margarin no
cooking oils and the and take the mighty
90 you take the mighty 90 and the odds
of you getting Alzheimer disease is zero
zero zero want you think about your
grandparents they have all the eggs and
all the cooking they did in lard and
everything they didn't have Alzheimer
disease they died 92 110 stuff like
that okay
next this is the US News were report
February of this year 2010 and they're
talking about the 80 million baby
boomers coming along living be 100 in
that upper right hand corner there it's
a summary of one of the chapters that
says seven habits that you can do to
lower your risk of Alzheimer's disease
that tells you right there that
Alzheimer's disease is not genetic
because there's no habit you can do
that's going to reduce the risk of a
genetic
disease see they know it seven habits
that you can do this can reduce your
risk of getting Alzheimer
disease don't eat fried foods don't eat
process meets with nitrates and
nitrites take the mighty 90 and you
won't get
it
next that's just some of that Mile and
shows all that fatty stuff around those
nerve fibers
next there's a tidal wave coming of Alys
disease because there's 80 million baby
boomers coming along who did whatever
the doctors told them I want to live to
be 100 I'm a baby boomer we want to be
the first generation where everybody
lives to be 100 will you lower your your
cholesterol and you'll live to be 100
give me give me give me I want the
newest I want the newest cholesterol
luring
drug give me an overdose of that one doc
well the unintended consequence is low
te
Ed and if you could remember Alzheimer
disease